je le sens bien que le plus gros que
j'ai fait j'étais crois que je partais
pour un pour un un salon de la télé par
une ville est en fait je suis parti une
semaine en vacances avec une une amie
ont été choppés
alors c'est quoi une amie une bonne amie
une camarade de jeu quoi
[Rires]
c'est très compliqué parce que j'ai dû
jouer sur les fuseaux horaires etc non
j'ai fini par faire gauler comme à
chaque fois évidemment sûr parce que
forcément j'ai oublié que l'ipad était
connecté à mon téléphone encore l'ipod
était resté à paris donc est ta meuf
elle te diffuser ce genre ouais tout va
bien mais elle savait très bien que ça
arrive et ça va je n'étais pas du tout
le devait être away c'était qu'elle
laquelle une femme alors je ne répondais
pas la question
avec la buse j'en ai fait d'autres mais
mais pas celle là la trois là je ne
répondrai pas la question
alors là quatre certaines n'ont pas
accédé une annonce ou remerciements pas
là oui moi je vais croire ma meuf que je
restais tard au bureau pour bosser mais
en fait j'étais au resto avec une très
belle mannequin qui était roumaine est
en fait ma meuf m'a vu au resto etc
cette meuf elle mais elle me dit c'est
qui elle je dois c'est ma comptable dans
la main ça n'émeuve c'est vrai dit bah
non non non je vous cache pas qu'on
avait un petit break après
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mal comptable
rouge ils n'ont jamais dansé vous que le
fatah
voilà ce genre de 2,2 délire oui vous
non moi sage comme une image raymond moi
j'étais jeune et en fait c'est du côté
de patiner
gt5 j'étais du côté d'opéra il y avait
un bar où les filles dansaient sur le
danser sur le bar en fait ça me donne
danser sur le bar du côté de l'opéra
romana world american je me souviens
plus trop de lumière et j'avais dit
grand-chose d'américains j'avais dit que
j'avais un tournoi de foot et où il ya
un foot en salle le soir et tout
nocturne et j'avais été là bas avec deux
potes à moi avec tony et jérôme g
balance banon s'est du coup à l'entrée à
l'entrée de cette botola celui qui
faisait la sécurité c'est le frère de ma
meuf à tout le monde sans faute
et le directeur général à hong kong ne
m'appelez maintenant dire reste une
faute professionnelle
ces relations il a dû faire une erreur
de mener cette année puis sur valider
vous a grillé je n'ai jamais été fait
griller par le frère je savais pas qu'il
faisait de la sécu a en fait il faisait
des trucs d'intérim et étend ses cours
moyen du renvoi intégral yuuwaa textile
et là il est là j'ai un pote mois il
faisait toujours point sa meuf en fait
quand il est mort une autre note qu'ils
aillent ferme il allait faire un tennis
pour ça que sert le foot ça c'est en
fait ce qui faisait imité avant de
rentrer à la maison ils se mettaient en
short il mettait le chauffage à fond
après nature fenêtres ouvertes et il
arrivait au nom
il restait dix minutes dans la voiture
comme ça le chauffage à fond comme sa
hanche rana et ses potes et bien sûr
c'est très facile
je n'ai pas d'induire